the director of the Federal Air Marshal
Service is responding to a scathing New
York Times report that claims the
organization has issues with alcohol
abuse harassment and low morale in its
ranks the service was created in 1961
and expanded after the September 11th
attacks
it has about 3,000 officers and an
annual budget of 800 million dollars
critics say it needs to be reformed or
possibly shut down Kris Van Cleave was
given special access to the Air Marshal
training center outside Atlantic City
New Jersey he's at the services field
office in Chantilly Virginia Chris good
morning good morning air marshals use
mock cabins like this one to train for
worst-case scenarios their mission is to
keep an airliner from being used as a
weapon and that requires some pretty
specialized training but the agency has
been faulted for not being able to
effectively show how good of a deterrent
it is to terrorism and this latest
controversy has some lawmakers asking if
it's a layer of security worth paying
for it's a scenario that should not
happen hijackers with a bomb on a u.s.
airliner but it's the type of situation
federal air marshals have been training
for around-the-clock in simulations like
this since 9/11 in my mind successes the
security of the traveling public and the
fact that we haven't had any major
incidents on US air carriers since 9/11
rod Allison is the director of the
Federal Air Marshal Service a force of
approximately 3,000 about half our
military veterans working undercover as
passengers charged with securing the
nation's 42,000 daily domestic and
international flights they're not on
every flight and we're not on board for
the failed shoe bomber or unsuccessful
underwear bomber
how many terror plots in flight have air
marshals disrupted well I can't point to
one that says this particular plot was
disrupted shouldn't you be able to doubt
now we have seen a number of plots
obviously over the years of which the
Air Marshal Service has provided added
security
next month the Government Accountability
Office will begin a review of the
working environment at the agency dogged
by complaints of low morale harassment
and alcohol abuse how big of an issue do
you feel alcohol abuse is currently
within your ranks do I see where people
get in trouble like any other large
organization with without home
absolutely but do I see it as order I
think it's abuse no I do not last year
an Inspector General report found
limitations with contributions to
aviation security and recommended
shutting down some operations to better
use resources it's just money going down
a rat hole and doing no good whatsoever
Congressman John Dunkin a Tennessee
Republican wants to end the program if
it was up to me we wouldn't still have
it because I think it's the most
needless useless wasteful organization
in the entire federal government and
that's saying a lot what is not in
question is the agency's focus on
training we were invited inside the
Federal Air Marshal Training Center in
Atlantic City the training is intense
and not only highlights marksmanship but
also quick decision making firearms
instructor Gary Dekker at 37,000 feet we
can't call for backup number one and
we're in such a confined space if we
can't make mistakes
Michael LaFrance joined the air marshals
after 9/11 and now helps run the
training center we've reinforced the
cockpit doors you have vet people better
before they get on the planes
you've armed pilots you're an Air
Marshal why do you need to be on a plane
the armored cockpit doors the other
layers of security there is fail points
there and the air marshals are there as
the last line of defense and take
control if there is a hostile act
against an aircraft the TSA
administrator tells CBS this morning he
does not see any systemic problems with
the Air Marshal Service and says he
believes those days are in the TSA s
past air marshals have never had to
engage a terrorist or a hijacker and the
agency only makes a handful of arrests a
year but says arrests aren't the main
goal and that air marshals are called
upon every couple of weeks to deal with
disruptive passengers Gayle all right
Kris Van Cleave it's a very interesting
question it'll be interesting to see if
they figured I personally like having
knowing that there's an Air Marshal on
the flight you know
the people say what good are they
they're plenty good when they're when
they get called into action well it's
also hard to determine the deterrent
effect yeah I think they're one of the
passengers might be an Air Marshal
I know perhaps it makes you pause if
you're up to no good that is any
thoughts no don't know I like earmark
okay especially with this all these
disruptive passengers I thank you and I
think as long as there are threats it's
a good thing we'll see what happens
thank you again Chris Van Cleve